ce n'est pas sur les plages mais sur les
tatamis que les filles de l'équipe de
france de judo passent leur été
après la normandie c'est à montpellier
qu'elle se prépare s'ils travaillaient
tous mes sensations comme si on revient
de deux blessures ce qui a fait une
grosse blessure
bah du coup voilà j'ai recherché mes
repères et surtout chercher le plaisir
est un peu de folie mais après je me
sens bien je me sens confiante j'ai pas
de p&g plus de pépins physiques donc on
va dire que la balle est dans mon camp
car automne pavia n'a qu'un objectif en
tête aller décrocher l'or l'an dernier
elle avait dû se contenter du bronze
ah oui surtout que moi c'est une
médaille que j'étais encore médaille
d'or donc
c'est sûr j'y vais pour ça on dit
souvent qu'on affronte plus des défaites
que de victoires est en fait je pense
que c'est vrai même si ça fait beaucoup
plus mal
mais voilà donc je pense que oui je
pense que depuis vingt deux ans même
l'année dernière j'ai appris des choses
et tout et je pense que ça va m'aider
pour ce championnat et au delà de cette
médaille d'or dont elle répond tant ces
championnats du monde qui seront les
derniers avant les jeux de rio auront
aussi un autre enjeu comme il ya un
système de ranking list et 14 premières
de la ranking mondial participeront aux
jeux olympiques et ce championnat du
monde qui va compter à 100% et les
enfants mais attention de ne pas avoir
leur garde robe portée sur vidéo sous
peine de se retrouver au tapis